let's talk about io which is the moon
of uh jupiter right okay it's like epic
there's like volcanoes all over the
place
it's um from a distance it's awesome so
can you tell me about this
moon and you're sort of uh a scholar of
many
planets and moons but that one kind of
stood out to me so why is that an
interesting one
for so many reasons but uh io is it is
the most volcanically active object in
the solar system it has hundreds of
active volcanoes on it
um it has volcanic plumes that go
hundreds of kilometers up above its
surface it puts out
more volume of magma per volcano than
volcanoes on earth today but
i think to me the reason that it's most
interesting is be
is as a laboratory for understanding
planetary processes
so one of the broad goals of planetary
science is to put together
a sort of more general and coherent
framework for how planets work
in general our current framework you
know it started out very earth-centric
we start to understand how earth
volcanoes work
um but then when you try to transport
that to somewhere like io that doesn't
have
an atmosphere which makes a or has a
very tenuous atmosphere which makes a
big difference for how the the magmady
gases
for something that's really small for
something that has a different heat
source for something that's embedded in
another object's magnetic field
the kind of intuition we have from earth
doesn't apply and so broadly
planetary sciences is trying to broaden
that framework
so that you have a kind of narrative
that all you can understand how each
planet became different from
every other planet and i'm already
making a mistake when i say planet i
mean planets and moons
like i said i see the moons as planets
yeah i actually already noticed that you
didn't introduce io as the moon of
jupiter
you you completely you uh you kind of
ignored the fact that
jupiter exists it's like let's focus on
this
yeah okay so uh and you also didn't
mention europa
which i think is the is is that the most
famous moon of jupiter
it's like no one gets attention because
it might have life exactly
yeah yeah but you're it but to you io is
also beautiful
i what's the difference between
volcanoes on io
versus earth you said atmosphere makes a
difference
what uh yeah the heat source plays a big
role so
many of the moons in the outer solar
system are heated from gravitationally
by
tidal heating um and i'm happy to
describe what that is or
yeah please okay um yes so tidal heating
is it's if you want to understand and
contextualize planets and moons you have
to understand their heat sources
so for earth we have radioactive decay
in our interior as well as residual heat
of formation
but for satellites tidal heating plays a
really significant role and in
particular
in driving geological activity on
satellites
and potentially making those subsurface
oceans in places like europa enceladus
habitable and so the way that that works
is if you have multiple moons
and their orbital periods are integer
multiples of one another
that means that they're always
encountering each other
at the same point in the orbit
so if they were on just random orbits
they'd be encountering each other at
random places and the gravitational
effect between the two moons would be
canceling out over time but because
they're always meeting each other at the
same point in the orbit
uh those gravitational interactions add
up coherently
um and so that tweaks them into
eccentric orbits
so eccentric orbit or elliptical orbit
it just means non-circular so a
deviation from a circular orbit and that
means
that you know for io or europa it's some
points in their orbit they're closer to
jupiter and at some points in the orbit
they're farther away
and so when they're closer they're
stretched out in a sense but but
literally just not
very stretched out like a couple hundred
meters something like that and then when
they're farthest away
they're less stretched out and so you
actually have the shape of the object
deforming over the course of the orbit
and these orbits are like just a couple
of days
and so that in the case of io that is
literally
sufficient friction in its mantle to
melt the rock of its mantle
and that's what generates the magma
that's that's the source of the
the okay so why is your so europa
is i thought there's like ice and oceans
underneath kind of thing
so why is europe not getting the
friction it is it's just a little bit
farther away from jupiter and then
ganymede is also in
the orbital resonance so it's a three
object orbital resonance
in the jupiter system but we have these
sorts of orbital resonances all over the
solar system and also in exoplanets
so for europa basically because it's
farther from jupiter
the effect is not as extreme but you do
still have heat
generated in its interior in this way
and that may be driving
could be driving hydrothermal activity
at the base of its ocean
which obviously would be a really
valuable thing for life
cool so it's like heating up the ocean a
little bit
heating up the ocean a little bit and
specifically in these like hydrothermal
vents where we see really interesting
uh life evolve in the bottom of earth's
oceans
that's cool okay so what's uh what's i o
uh what else so we know the source is
this friction
but there's no atmosphere i'm trying to
get a sense of what it's like if if you
and i were to visit
io like what would that look like would
it feel like
is it is the entire thing covered in
basically
uh volcanoes um
so it's it's interesting because there's
very little atmosphere the surface is
actually
really cold very far below freezing on
the surface when you're away from a
volcano but the volcanoes themselves
are over a thousand degrees or the the
magma when it comes out is over a
thousand degrees
and so but it does come to the surface
the magma it does
yeah in particular places
oh that probably looks beautiful so like
so it's
frozen not ice like what is uh is rock
it's really cold rock and then you just
have this like uh
what is what does that look what would
that look like with no atmosphere
would that uh would it be smoke
what does it look like was it's just
magma like just red
uh yellow like liquidy things uh it's
it's black it's black and red i guess
like think of
the type of magma that you see in hawaii
so different types of magma
flow in different ways for example so in
somewhere like io the magma is really
hot and so it will flow out in
sheets because it has really low
viscosity
um and i think the the lava flows that
we've been having
in hawaii over the past couple years are
probably a decent analogy although
io's magmas lavas are even more fluid
and
and faster moving how fast like what uh
how fat like
if you oh by the way sorry through the
telescope
are you tracking at what time scale like
what the for every frame
is how far apart if you're looking for a
telescope are we talking about
seconds or we're talking about days
months
when you kind of track try to get a
picture of what the surface might look
like
what's the frequency so it depends a
little bit on what you want to do
i ideally every night
um but you could take a frame every
second and see how things are changing
the the problem with that is that for
things to change on a one
second time scale you to actually see
something change that fast you have to
have super high
resolution the spatial resolution we
have is a couple hundred kilometers and
so
okay things are not changing on those
scales over one second
unless you have something really crazy
happening
so if you get you if you get a telescope
closer to io
if you get uh or a camera closer to io
would you be able to understand
something is that something of interest
to you
it would you be able to understand
something deeper about
these volcanic eruptions and how magma
flows and
just the like the rate of the magmas or
is it basically
enough to have the kilometer resolution
no way
we want to go there you want to go you
want to go to iowa i mean i don't want
to go there personally but i want to
send a spacecraft mission there
absolutely why why are you scared
why am i scared oh you mean you know
uh like you uh i don't want to go there
as a human as a human
i want to send a robot there to look at
it this is again everybody's
discriminating against robots this is
not
but it's fine uh but it's not hospitable
to uh humans in any way right
so it's very cold and very hot it's very
cold
um the atmosphere is composed of sulfur
dioxide
so you couldn't breathe it there's no
pressure i mean it's kind of all the
same things you talk about
one talks about about mars only worse
the atmosphere is still a thousand times
less dense than mars's
and the radiation environment is
terrible because you're embedded
deep within jupiter's magnetic field and
jupiter's magnetic field
is full of charged particles that have
all come
out of ios volcanoes actually so
juveder's magnetic field strips all this
material out of ios atmosphere
and that populates its entire
magnetosphere and then that material
comes back around and hits io and and
spreads throughout the system actually
it's just
it's like a io is the massive polluter
of the jupiter system
okay cool uh so what uh what is studying
io teach you about volcanoes on earth
or vice versa is in the difference of
the two
what insights can you mine out
that might be interesting in some way
yeah it's
we try to port the tools that we use to
study earth volcanism to io and it works
to some extent but
it is challenging um because
the situations are so different and the
compositions are really different when
you talk about
outgassing you know earth volcanoes
outgas primarily
uh water and carbon dioxide and then
sulfur dioxide is the the third most
abundant gas and and on io the water and
carbon dioxide are
not there either it didn't form with
them or
it lost them we don't know and so so the
chemistry of how the magma outgasses is
completely different
um but the the kind of one to me
most interesting analogy to earth is
that
um so io as i've said it has these
really low viscosity magmas the
the lava spreads really quickly across
its surface
it can put out massive volumes of magma
in relatively short periods of time
and that sort of volcanism is not
happening anywhere else in the solar
system today
but literally every terrestrial planet
and the moon
had this what we call very effusive
volcanism early in their history okay so
this is almost like a little glimpse
into the early history of earth yeah
okay cool so uh what are the chances
that uh a volcano on earth destroys all
of human civilization
maybe i wanted to sneak in that question
yeah a volcano on earth
um do you think about that kind of stuff
when you just
study volcanoes elsewhere because in it
kind of humbling to see something so
powerful
and so hot like so unpleasant for humans
and then you realize we're sitting on
many of them here right
yeah yellowstone as a classic example i
i don't
know what the chances are of that
happening my intuition would be that the
chances of that are lower than the
chances of
us getting wiped out by some other means
so that in the time
you know that maybe it'll happen
eventually that there will be one of
these massive volcanoes on earth but
we'll probably be gone by then by some
other means
not to sound bleak but it's very
comforting
you